[Música]
antes de que nos pegará el coronavirus
ya el mundo nos venía pegando una gran
paliza a todas las organizaciones si
nosotros vemos el cambio climático por
ejemplo nos exigía ecoeficiencia nos
estaba exigiendo menores emisiones que
cambiáramos empaques y embalajes que
redistribuye éramos las cadenas de valor
en fin una exigencia alta encima de esto
enfrentábamos la cuarta revolución
industrial que tenía impacto sobre todas
las organizaciones y todas las funciones
como hacemos todo prácticamente todo lo
que hacemos y esto afectaba a las
personas y las organizaciones de una
manera profunda y eso nos exigía cambiar
por supuesto estamos en un mundo donde
las cadenas de valor se han integrado
globalmente y así como hay grandes
retailers que compiten
internacionalmente tanto en términos
físicos como el caso de voz marte en
términos más grandes como el caso de
amazon en línea la verdad es que lo que
se ha dado es una concentración de la
actividad empresarial en marcas cada vez
más globales que desplazan a
competidores locales y esto nos ha
llevado a una
centra ción de la riqueza verdaderamente
alarmante antes cuando hablábamos de la
base de la pirámide pensábamos que
estábamos hablando de un sector de
pobreza hoy vemos que el 64%
prácticamente de la población mundial
concentra apenas el 1.9 por ciento de la
riqueza y el 9 y medio por ciento más
rico ni siquiera el 10% el 84 por ciento
claramente teníamos que empezar a
activar estrategias muy diferentes a
cualquier cosa que hemos hecho en el
pasado para mantenerse vigente en el
mundo había que competir
internacionalmente este gráfico nos
muestra como desde 1960 la actividad
económica ha crecido fundamentalmente en
ocho y media veces al mismo tiempo que
el comercio internacional ha crecido 43
y media veces eso significa por un lado
que cada ciudadano del 2020 de cinco y
media veces más rico que cualquier
ciudadano de 1960 en promedio pero con
la distribución de riqueza que acabamos
de ver y la complicación que eso implica
para los mercados no cabe ninguna duda
que además
los millennials en particular que son
hoy la clase que son los hados los
jóvenes adultos y los que establecen los
patrones de consumo han cambiado su
forma de consumir su estilo de vida y
recurren a otros procesos de compra y
todo esto sin significaba una gran
tensión para las empresas y sin duda
alguna verdad la economía mundial
interconectada a tal punto que aparece
un virus en la provincia de hubei en
china y poco tiempo después la economía
globalizada colapsa frente a nuestros
ojos 60 días después estamos viendo un
colapso total del turismo de las bolsas
de valores el sector financiero bajo
gran estrés y en fin enormes retos todo
esto ya existía si ustedes se acuerdan
en este siglo empezamos con una
disrupción global muy curiosa en
realidad justo antes de empezar el siglo
porque ya en el año 2000 verdad nos
estábamos todos preocupando de que el
white two que aquella incapacidad de las
computadoras de actualizar las fechas al
0 10 100 de una manera coordina
llegó a que nos diera miedo que
colapsara toda la conectividad y todos
los sistemas de cómputo del mundo
afortunadamente no ocurrió pero no
ocurrió en buena parte porque
reaccionamos a tiempo y trabajamos
juntos para evitarlo y esta es una
lección que desafortunadamente parecemos
no haber aprendido si vemos lo que ha
ocurrido en este siglo primero el 11 de
septiembre del 2001 tuvimos el impacto
causado en esa instancia por terrorismo
en el 2008 la crisis de las hipotecas
que nos vino a golpear y otra vez una
caída de la economía mundial y ahora
estamos recibiendo todo el impacto del
móvil 19 de esta pandemia global que no
sabemos de qué tamaño va a ser la caída
pero que ciertamente ya se prevé que va
a ser más grande que las anteriores no
sabemos hasta dónde nos va a devolver en
términos de nuestro ingreso nacional o
ingreso per cápita ni tampoco cómo será
la recuperación si vamos a salir con
gran energía creciendo más rápidamente
si vamos a salir a una pendiente más
baja por el enorme golpe que se sufre en
el empleo que se sufre en la inversión o
si inclusive nos vamos a estar
por un tiempo antes de volver a crecer y
es que este siglo en promedio cada 6.6
años nos ha golpeado con una disrupción
mayor esas tres que acabamos de ver pero
ojo que tuvimos señales de aviso el sars
y el a h1n1 nos avisaron que las
pandemias eran peligrosas y aunque esas
no explotaron al nivel que ya alcanzó el
coronavirus la verdad es que pocos
países y pocas organizaciones se
prepararon como debían además tenemos
todas estas otras disrupciones yo puse
aquí algunos conflictos armados que nos
golpean constantemente en precios de
commodities en precios del petróleo y en
fin están totalmente y constantemente
molestando la forma como tenemos que
manejar nuestras organizaciones si eso
fuera poco para hablar de costa rica- mi
país de origen
también tenemos disrupciones nacionales
verdad el terremoto de cinchona la
crisis política del 2004 el plan
obviamente el impacto de la disrupción
mayor del 2008 que llegó al plan escudo
que ha causado una sobrecarga de todos
los sistemas fiscales
otto y aquí me refiero al huracán solo
ser claro y no hablar de ninguna persona
y todo eso en un ambiente con un clima
de negocios más bien débil con costos
poco competitivos del capital costos
poco competitivos de la energía por
ejemplo un profundo déficit fiscal que
llegaba al 7 por ciento al cierre del
año 2019 y una crisis de confianza entre
los sectores
ciertamente no las condiciones ideales
para abordar una crisis como la que
estamos enfrentando y es que entonces la
pregunta va a ser cuánta cuánto falta
para la próxima crisis si de verdad son
cada 6 puntos 6 años cuando nos vuelve a
golpear y de cuál duración será yo
marque ahí el 2038 como un punto de
corte porque de acuerdo a la longevidad
promedio de mi país ahí es donde yo me
bajó de la nave y me voy a donde sea que
va uno después de la muerte pero el
hecho es que si seguimos cada seis
puntos seis años vamos a celebrar mi
funeral con una crisis global adicional
verdad si se mantiene el ritmo que
llevamos ahora y la verdad es pensarían
ustedes que hemos llegado al final de
estas crisis posiblemente no
yo lo que los quiero invitar es a que
pensemos que ha llegado la hora de
cambiar estar listos para no ser
apaleados en nuestras organizaciones no
sólo por las crisis sino por las
situaciones coyunturales que se viven en
nuestro propio país y en ese sentido
vamos a tener que pensar como
reorganizamos el talento humano vamos a
trabajar más desde la casa vamos a
trabajar en unidades distribuidas qué
habilidades y destrezas que sistemas de
compensación o supervisión vamos a
utilizar vamos a tener que enfocarnos en
productos y servicios que tenemos que
rediseñar en función del cambio
climático pero también en elementos por
ejemplo de cómo transmite un contagio no
se nos había ocurrido mucho antes vamos
a tener que adaptarnos a nuevas cadenas
de distribución y por lo tanto a lo
mejor tenemos que rediseñar para que
puedan ser movidos en esas cadenas de
distribución y eso significa que tenemos
que articular las cadenas de valor tal
vez no depender de un mono suplidor en
un gran país como china sino tener
suplidores distribuidos tener
distribuidores físicos pero también
distribuidores en línea y de nuevo
sistema
de entrega y de alguna manera pensar
cómo es que vamos a ir nosotros de una
manera clara integrando una cadena de
valor que no solo tenga equilibrio entre
sus márgenes sino que distribuya
adecuadamente el riesgo entre sus
miembros en los procesos productivos van
a tener que cambiar vamos a depender más
de robótica digitalización internet de
las cosas formas de automatización
inteligencia artificial y esto qué
significa para el empleo y para las
capacidades que debo tener en la empresa
para administrar estos procesos
ciertamente yo no me imagino que después
de esta experiencia salgamos igual y por
último enfoquémonos en la estrategia
cómo vamos entonces a gestionar el
talento humano ya lo dijimos mercado
regional o mercado global queremos una
posición más robusta en el mercado local
y el mercado regional que nos permita
realmente tener una salvaguarda en caso
de que se dé una crisis global como la
que vivimos nuestro capex en tecnología
tiene que cambiar radicalmente a la luz
de los cambios en cadena de valor y
procesos que acabamos de mencionar
ciertamente todo este tema de la gestión
y el análisis de datos el big data
verdad se vuelve una necesidad
fundamental se vuelve algo que vamos a
tener que enfocar con otros ojos y con
otras capacidades y lo más importante
para mí el gobierno corporativo yo soy
de la opinión que los mismos siete
viejos con los mismos trajes las mismas
camisas las mismas corbatas sentados
alrededor de la misma mesa difícilmente
van a tomar las decisiones necesarias
vamos a tener que pensar en cómo
reestructurar los gobiernos corporativos
los equipos ejecutivos para hacer mucho
más representativos de ese futuro que se
nos viene encima y de las habilidades
que requiero tener para realmente
adaptar la estrategia y subsistir en el
ies que si vemos la estrategia como una
puerta con ventana donde puedo
visualizar grandes oportunidades en el
futuro y tal vez logró abrir esa puerta
para pasar y aprovechar esas
oportunidades y eso es mi negocio actual
acabamos de recibir un golpe que no solo
me interrumpe la vista
sino que me deja un gran hoyo me deja un
espacio donde perdí ingresos perdí
rentabilidad perdí ciertamente capital
humano posiblemente perdí suscriptores
entonces tenemos que pensar en que vamos
a tener que ir a una etapa de adaptación
y ajuste vamos a tener que hacer un
remiendo para rescatar mi empresa y
poder seguir adelante pero más
importante vamos a tener que consolidar
aquellas partes de nuestro negocio que
sí tengan sentido en ese futuro y más
importante todavía con nueva visión y
comprensión de lo que viene habiendo
entendido lo que el mundo nos va a
apretar y nos va a seguir prestando
tanto antes de la crisis del virus como
a raíz de la crisis del virus
identificar y aprovechar las
oportunidades y negocios emergentes para
establecer una nueva forma de operar
esto implica también que vamos a tener
que cabildear y trabajar al lado del
gobierno recuperar la confianza entre
sectores para crear un clima de negocios
que la próxima vez que tengamos una
crisis de esta magnitud
de los retos que de por sí ya teníamos
encima no nos vengamos no los tengamos
que enfrentar con una profundo déficit
fiscal con gran desconfianza y con todo
aquello que mencioné realmente
necesitamos ordenar nos en casa para
estar listos para la próxima y más
importante nosotros tenemos que dar
tanto como exigimos si vamos a cabildear
ya trabajar con el gobierno para
exigirle vamos a tener que dar mucho y
eso significa ir a un capitalismo
solidario y es aquel capitalismo que
desde qué stephan schmidheiny por un
lado el consejo mundial empresarial para
el desarrollo sostenible la cumbre de la
tierra en río de janeiro lo plantearon a
partir de 1992
hemos discutido tiene muchos elementos
ya es hora de que debemos de hablar de
ellos como algo que está por ahí y que
tiene un valor y lo convirtamos en la
esencia de nuestra estrategia no es que
estemos a tiempo el golpe enorme nos lo
vamos a llevar lo que sí les aseguro es
que si no salimos como un nuevo enfoque
y como una nueva estrategia
y vamos a volver a sufrir golpes como
este en vez de esperar los bien
preparados como debe ser muchas gracias
[Música]